there's a talked about the new front on
LGBT rights now that gay marriage is
legal the legality of firing people
based on their sexual orientation
so-called religious freedom bills that's
the sort of new front against LGBT
rights to take one example currently in
Missouri like in many states it's
illegal to fire someone merely for being
gay last week the Missouri State House
of Representatives was debating a bill
that would protect LGBT people from
being fired for their sexual orientation
things ended up going backwards okay the
amendment protecting gay people was
removed and they ended up passing a bill
that would make it more difficult for
all people to sue for discriminatory
termination from their jobs and while
they were debating there's this
Republican state representative in
Missouri I should say Missouri that's I
guess that's how it's said right I think
either one is accepted okay very good
Missouri Republican Missouri State
Representative Rick brattin
was against keeping the language in the
bill that would have protected gay
people he basically said on the House
floor that gay people are not really
people okay here's what he said quote
when you look at the tenets of religion
of the Bible of the Koran of other
religions there is a distinction between
homosexuality and just being a human
being this is not just a reprehensible
thing to say on a moral level it's
legally fallacious based on a document
that people like Bratton claimed to pray
at the altar of we know it is the
Constitution number one you've got this
thing called the Equal Protection Clause
of the 14th amendment which guarantees
equal protection of all people under the
law unless you can legally demonstrate
that a gay person is not homo sapiens
the Constitution does not distinguish
between LGBT people and other people and
the Supreme Court has actually affirmed
that and number two he's citing holy
books as justification for
discrimination against LGBT people by
the government that defines that defies
the Establishment Clause of the First
Amendment separation of church and
but what's most intolerable about
Bratten statements is the contempt he's
showing for people in his state right
there are LGBT Missourians who are
presumably finding out about what
Bratton said and this is someone who's
supposed to be there to represent them
he's been asked for comment he hasn't
responded this is not just ignorance at
the level of a single person to say
something so stupid this is the general
attitude and rationale of many
conservatives now that want to deny LGBT
people there right now that gay marriage
has been legalized and of course he's
bringing religion into this conversation
which is not commonplace I mean you
can't have that when we have the First
Amendment guarantee if separation of
church and state correct but since he's
bringing up political or to be bringing
up the Bible it's important to point out
that the Bible also says he who is
without sin cast the first stone
meaning possibly he's gay himself and
it's just projecting it onto other
people obviously not all homophobes are
gay but the number of religious
conservatives who have devoted their
lives to making the lives of LGBT people
miserable who have later sort of come
out as gay or lesbian or bisexual or
transgender it's odd it's very very odd
and it does point to this idea that
sometimes because you are not able to
live in the world the way you truly
authentically feel you don't want
anybody who to be able to live in the
world in that way and that's actually
sad I mean I I know that we've talked
about this many times Pat about the
homophobes who are gay it's actually a
really sad thing because clearly their
lives are difficult as a result of not
being able to live in the world as who
they are and they're also making the
lives of other people more difficult
right exactly but you can't feel too
badly about that even though they're
obviously conflicted in there and
they're inside their own head because
they're trying to make life worse for
everyone else this also proves that
anyone who says hey religion and
politics is good they're wrong right I
mean Pat's pointing that out these types
of conservative politicians have
religious beliefs that they believe to
be sort of literal worldly beliefs and
when they apply them to the way that
governments govern those beliefs have
two cleanses and in this case people are
being denied what should be basic rights
how many months by the way before this
guy gets caught performing sex acts on a
man in a public bathroom would anyone be
surprised if this guy ends up adopting a
wide stance in an airport men's room
like former Republican Senator Larry
Craig but that aside Bratton is a guy
who's advocated teaching creationism in
public schools in science class he's
pushed for a law that would require the
permission of a father for a young woman
to get an abortion
he was an ally a fellow Republican
Missouri State Representative Todd akin
who's famous for saying if it's a
legitimate rape the female body has a
way to try to shut the whole thing down
this is a damaging individual to the
lives of so many men women LGBT
individuals and this is the exact it's
just a microcosm of who we should not
have determining the direction of
government at the state or federal level
a couple of discussions about this on
our reddit discussion forum which I
invite you to join at david pakman.com
/r edit today's program is made possible
in part by Gamefly which is sort of like
Netflix for video games they've got over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can also stream
games you don't even need a gaming
console or a computer because you can
stream games through your Amazon fire
stick or Roku box and then use your
mobile phone as the controller you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price never with due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
30-day free trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30 day trial for
david pakman show viewers and listeners
and support our show at Gamefly offered
calm /td PS